la France sera plus forte dans ce monde
de bouleversement si nous sommes d'abord
plus
unis si nous réapprenons à partager des
valeurs une culture commune le sens du
respect dans les salles de classe dans
la rue dans les transports comme dans
les
commerces c'est pourquoi comme je l'ai
indiqué le 31 décembre dernier lors de
mes vœux nous engagerons un réarmement
civique chaque génération de
français doit apprendre ce que la
République veut dire
une histoire des devoirs des droits une
langue un
imaginaire le sens profond du respect et
de l'engagement et cela dès l'enfance en
renforçant le soutien et l'exigence
vis-à-vis des
parents en reprenant aussi le contrôle
de nos écrans qui trop souvent enferment
là où il devrait libérer sur la base de
recommandations que font les experts que
j'ai réunis la semaine dernière nous
déterminerons le bon usage des écrans
pour nos enfants dans les familles à la
maison comme en classe parce qu'il en va
de l'avenir de nos sociétés et de nos
démocratie à l'école ensuite depuis 2017
nous avons entamé un choc des savoirs le
retour des fondamentaux l'enseignement
le dédoublement des classes et nous
allons le poursuivre avec des maîtres
mieux formés mieux payés une rénovation
des programmes des évaluations en chaque
niveau dès la rentrée 2024
l'instruction civique sera refondée son
volume horaire sera doublé une heure par
semaine dès la saè avec en appui les
grands textes fondateurs de la
nation et l'école dans laquelle la
confiance aussi se déploie où on forge
pleinement et on exprime les talents de
chacun doit donner une place à la
culture et au
sport c'est pourquoi nous avons instauré
la demi-heure de sport quotidienne en
primaire et 2 heures supplémentaires par
semaine au
collège au-delà de cela l'éducation
artistique et culturelle que nous avons
déployé dans nos écoles depuis
maintenant un peu plus de 6 ans va se
renforcer comme pour la musique et les
arts plastiques je souhaite que le
théâtre devienne un passage obligé au
collège dès la rentrée
prochaine parce que cela donne confiance
cela apprend l'oralité le contact au
grand texte et parce que la France est
aussi une histoire un patrimoine qui se
transmet et qui unit l'histoire de l'art
retrouvera sa place à la rentrée
prochaine au collège et au
lycée la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à
tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre pays et qui efface les inégalités
entre les famillees en même temps
qu'elle crée les conditions du respect
sera expérimenté dès cette année dans
une centaine
d'établissements tous
volontaires cette expérimentation sera
évaluée
méthodiquement et sur la base des
résultats s'ils sont concluants nous la
généraliserons en
2026 nous instituerons dans chaque
collège et dans chaque lycée dès la fin
de cette année une cérémonie de remise
des diplômes rite républicain d'unité de
fierté et de
reconnaissance la famille et l'école au
fond pour faire des républicains en même
temps que pour transmettre des
savoirs